[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum ryan how are you i'm
good man it's been a whirlwind of [ __ ]
hasn't it considering yeah i mean gosh
you went off to ireland to a wedding
everybody everybody at covid you didn't
get it except for me somehow i went to
palm springs i went all over the world
and then went to palm springs i got
covered jesus and now i'm uh recovered
it's uh it's a lot it was a lot and now
blanche is coming to the room here my
dog blanche if you guys don't know
blanche hey blanche uh great
episode today looking very forward to it
uh just a few things to remind you about
um
my new show talkville uh a re-watch
podcast with my co-star tom welling is
every wednesday you could watch it or
listen to it on wherever you find your
podcast ryan yep is has some major
involvement in this i am i'm watching
smallville for the first time and uh
yeah i got it now it's time i got an
outsider's perspective on it yeah i love
that blanche joined us this is a real
treat why not have her in here if you're
watching you can see blanche uh also if
you want to join patreon the top tier
patrons uh or just patreon in general to
support the podcast give a little extra
to the podcast it means the world go to
patreon.com inside of you i will write
you a message after uh it really helps
you guys do so much for the podcast and
i'll read the top tier uh patrons uh
names out at the end of the podcast so
stay tuned
also you can go to the inside of you
online store and get great merch uh
autographed smallville stuff and much
much more you might want to do that
there's some stuff that's only going to
be there for a limited time little zip
up jackets ryan the little side
jackets and much more also follow us um
uh on on twitter instagram and facebook
ryan pat inside of you pod on twitter
inside of your podcast on instagram and
facebook i will be in raleigh north
carolina with tom welling july 30th and
31st doing the smallville nights on july
29th uh if you in you're in the area
near raleigh i would suggest you get
tickets because it's going to be a lot
of fun everybody comes to smallville
nights has a blast
and then i'll be in boston august 12th i
believe so get your tickets to some cons
and come see me i'm also on that cameo
thing but today's guest is uh
you know
legend yeah he's a legend he's on on the
show the peacemaker james gunn's the
peacemaker he was in t2 terminator 2
all-time villain movie history oh yeah i
mean this guy's been around we had a
blast talking i was a little intimidated
by him yeah he's got an intimidating
presence but we hit it off and it felt
good and um i think you're gonna really
love this it's a really good episode i
had i'm saying this because i i know it
i remember this conversation well and uh
so without further ado let's get inside
of robert patrick it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
i feel like i need more support on this
couch is that true no disrespect do you
it's a little saggy is it all sad that's
all right no no no no i got i got that's
why i put the pillow underneath it's a
little too bob sag it's a little too
this is the way i like to start off all
my podcasts with an insult to the
to the host to the host oh by the way
the most i just by the way greetings
from
steve a age agent i love a.g a.g he
loves you uh i love steve uh he's just
one of the best sweet sweets one of the
most unique individuals i've ever met in
show business he's one of those guys
you're going to be here the whole time
kid yeah yeah quiet
you know what's funny is you're i looked
it up and you're not very old you're not
old
you're 63. that's not old that's [ __ ]
old do you feel old sometimes what is it
that makes you feel old body
from all the work you did like what did
you do a lot of stunts and [ __ ]
yeah body is and and my body is
relatively healthy compared to a lot of
people i know that uh and and endured uh
uh quite a few more uh uh
mishaps than i did or injuries that i
have uh so i feel on one hand
uh like i uh survived pretty much
unscathed without anything serious
happened to me no bad knee no bad hip no
bad this no bad nothing
but it's aches and pains it's it's just
aches and pains you're talking to mr a
payne i've had eight spine surgeries see
so neck back playing sports my whole
life early on doing my own stunts
thinking oh i can do this ice hockey
you know wrestle a little football
baseball tennis all that stuff yeah ice
hockey's uh is a is a is a high impact
uh sport yeah so i'm sure you get a lot
of injuries that way yeah i i i i think
it's just aches and pains
do you what do you do you take tylenol
for it do you stretch in the morning way
too many advils uh i'm also on relief
factor which is a uh
what's that it's uh it's a it's a it's a
it's a
a product that uh has a lot of turmeric
in it you have to look it up you're
left-handed
yeah that's good are you two yeah sweet
i just write down relief factor relief
factor it's got a lot of turmeric in it
you take it like three days uh
i'm i'm a sucker for all those kind of
stuff matter of fact my wife just looks
at my uh my uh supplement drawer and
just goes jesus christ do you use them
do you try
anything does anything help
uh
i do feel great right now you do i was a
little bit out of breath coming up your
stairs that's a lack of cardio and a
serious uh uh
smoking uh cigar smoking habit
oh yeah by the way james gunn i just
asked him i texted him and he said i
said what can i ask him he said ask him
how he enjoyed the cigars i gave him
well let me tell you what he gave me a
box on the last day of shooting of
partagas series d number fours
and he is what's that those are that
yeah those are the cuban cigars that he
smokes those are his cigars are they
illegal in the states nothing's illegal
in the united states okay all right good
good you know come on uh everything's
legal here uh
james gave me a box uh we were we were
in canada so i don't know what the laws
were in canada uh and they were fabulous
we were talking cigars i used to show up
on the set with a cigar
sometimes when i'm you know uh
performing uh uh
you show up to work uh i i've always had
a nicotine habit uh either cigarettes or
chewing tobacco and uh
um
it's
i it's it's co-exists with my uh my my
world as a performer so i like to chew
on cigars if i don't necessarily smoke
them right so he would see me doing that
but you don't smoke cigarettes anymore
you don't shoot tobacco anymore
or is it on occasion yeah it depends
i mean i could
i mean i could just fall off the [ __ ]
wagon you could have a dart right i
could go right now and go you can go
outside you could do it you see don't
lose that craving
i
have not i mean i've i don't really
seriously have a a desire to smoke
cigarettes anymore i can i can feel the
rattling around going on in there and
i'm not too crazy about it right my
father died of lung cancer
uh you know my fate is sort of i think
uh pre-ordained uh
you know how old was he a was 80. all
right eighteen
years you know based on his clocks
um who knows
uh
he was a big smoker he was he quit uh
yeah i was thinking about my dad
recently because he has passed away and
uh it's mother's day and i'm thinking
about uh mother's day is coming up and
i'm thinking about my mom she was 20
when she had me
she was 20 20 my mom was 23 and my dad
was 19 when they had me oh my god where
are you from again i grew up in indiana
but i was from i'm from new york i grew
up in a small town in indiana
so you grew up in jordan georgia you
were all over the place i was michigan
ohio i was all over the place right yeah
atlanta boston dayton detroit cleveland
when people ask me where i'm from that's
what i say atlanta boston dayton detroit
galileo jesus was that horror growing up
moving around oh yeah oh yeah how so
well
you you really have to kind of look at
it from
where it was in history i mean i was
born in 58 in the deep south
i was raised in the deep south in the
60s
my father was a new englander
he was a college graduate my mother was
a cracker
okay she was a a a white girl raised in
marietta georgia got through high school
went to work at lockheed aircraft
corporation at 19.
my dad fell in love with her love at
first sight three weeks they were
married three weeks they got married at
19. and he was like her night in shining
armor so he was her first love uh she
had had some other boyfriends i think in
high school oh my mother was a looker so
she had uh she had her share of guys
that we're after you know and uh right
but i think my dad just swept her off
her feet he was a colleague he was a
sophisticated college educated guy i
believe he was like
i'm going to say he was probably about
21 you graduate college you're like 24
23
24. and uh you know i was thinking about
it because i've seen a picture of my
father who who's sitting in front of you
sitting in front of a uh ford i believe
it was called a sun liner
that sounds familiar like a 56 or 57
black and white he has on a suit he's
smoking a cigar
he's got his glasses on he looks cool as
[ __ ] probably the coolest he's ever
looked in his life
and he sit standing for me and he had to
sell that car when my my mother got
pregnant
and they had me and i'm you know
with everything that's going on right
now in our society with all this stuff
yeah it just really made me think about
man i'm lucky to be here
yeah you know
thank you mom
right
his mom with you thank you for having me
is mom still with you
you probably had a choice
my dad said i gotta sell the car to have
this kid
right right you know what i'm saying
yeah thank you is your mom still with
you she is she's older she's she's 83
she's exactly 20 years older than me wow
is she is she uh you guys still close
very much you talk to her how often
every freaking day really about it's a
treasure about anything anything how are
you what's going on what are you doing
she's interested in your life always has
been always been supportive always
supportive i think part of the reason
why i became an actor was for her really
i think she wanted to be an actress
she was pretty enough and she fancied
herself as a like a model
you know i got to see a picture now well
i'll show you do i have a phone did i
bring my phone i don't know i don't know
it might be in your car no it might be
your fancy car that you drive oh come on
that was a fancy loud car was like what
the hell's outside that's just the
engine roaring out there that's just a
dodge
hellcat it's a size 100 7 horsepower you
got to dip it down into your detroit
voice
a dodge what is it dodge hellcat the old
dodge hellcat 707 horsepower 707 of pure
muscle detroit muscles
michael i love you already buddy so i'm
when's part two when do i come back and
do before exactly that's it man we're
done but james gave me going back to
james i don't know i don't lose it
gave me that cigar and i i smoked them
i enjoyed them they were the best cigars
and now i'm addicted to partagas series
d but they're a little pricier for he's
in a different uh economic uh category
category than myself yeah i still got a
boy in college and uh you know so
i knew james when he wasn't in such a
category he was he was you know he was
just he was fighting he was doing all
right but he wasn't i mean guardians of
the galaxy guy peacemaker guy yeah he uh
he became that guy oh he worked hard his
story is fascinating yeah all the
brothers and the sister he has grown up
in st louis and by the way he wants to
know if you're going to the wedding
i am are you yeah yeah i'm going oh yeah
you're going to go oh yeah you're going
to go in aspen yeah why not come on do
it my wife wants to do it i want to do
it i love jen i think she's great
i love james i don't know james as well
as you i've just worked for him he loves
you though he loves you
it's you know why does he love you why
do people like you so much because i
mean you know i read somewhere it's like
jason bateman says you're one of the one
of the heavies of the acting world
you're like people are always talking
highly about
ah she's a beauty look at her ryan look
at the picture of his mom she's 19. she
was
oh man she's a beauty right let me see
that picture i could probably it's like
she's 16 or 17 there what a smile she's
just a sweetheart
i think that's like in high school i
don't know how old she is there but i
saw that and i went like you know god
bless her i mean you know i mean you
think about your parents and you think
about how they grow up when
they grow up when
they're you're growing up yeah it's it's
a simultaneous thing
um
james and i were trying to figure out
where we met to do when we were when we
were doing peacemaker he alluded to the
fact that possibly i had read for him
for slithers
slither or excuse me slytherin i didn't
mean plurals oh you read for that for
the lead part i think so
and then he gave it to rooker and he
gave it to rooker because
uh
james and his inevitable way of making
you feel good he said something offhand
like i think you were too good looking
well you know it was what was the sweet
thing to say you know what i think that
that would probably hurt rooker's
feelings it might and i don't want to
look i don't want to hurt worker
feelings because i love rucker i love
rooker i love he doesn't love rooker
i've done two movies you'll record
what'd you do with rooker i did it i did
a great movie
uh in cleveland ohio about a rogue uh
swat team force it was an exploitation
film it's not you know it's you know one
of those films right and a rooker is an
fbi hrt agent and i am a swat team
leader in cleveland
and i become judge jury and executioner
for bad guys wow and the whole thing is
like a it's like
you know it's a like a chess
chess game of him trying to find out who
it is and we're doing what we're doing
and we're
and a
big showdown in a big park in downtown
cleveland ohio the exec the the producer
of it was a a gentleman named alan
schechter who was from joel silver's
uh
action movie and we patterned it after
the north hollywood uh shootout at the
bank that was the famous bank shootout
that happened in uh north hollywood in
the 90s i didn't even know about that oh
you know about that yeah no when did you
get here man i i i got here in 99
90 oh yeah so i missed it like i missed
it two things look it up big shootout so
we have this huge shootout in this big
park in cleveland it was beautiful
and uh and michael eventually gets me
and then he eventually becomes judge
jury and executioner and he kills me
inside of you is brought to you by helix
sleep guys i don't know what you think
is the most important thing in life but
i know that one of those
important things in life
sleep is sleep
if you're not getting a good night's
sleep
then there's something wrong you should
probably get a really good mattress and
helix sleep are the folks to help you do
so
i went years with bad mattresses and
back pain and if anybody knows
when they need comfort when they need to
get a good night's sleep i think it's me
so uh
you know there's a lot going on in the
world and
the only time you can really shut down
and get some rest and relaxation is at
night when you go to bed it's the most
important time
of the day really i think you gotta get
a good night's sleep uh helix sleep has
a quiz that takes just two minutes to
complete matches your body and type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else with
helix you're getting a mattress that you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot and even a helix plus mattress for
plus size sleepers i'm a medium guy i've
always been a medium guy and helix
really does it for me i took the helix
quiz it was so easy even i could pass it
guys this is a really fast little quiz
just so it knows your body type your you
know the the things that make you you
and it will help you uh pick out the
perfect mattress it's been awesome
getting messages from so many of you
guys talking about helix and how you
love it uh if you're looking for a
mattress just take the quiz order the
mattress that you're matched to and the
mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again and helix
is so awesome
um but you know you don't need to take
my word for it helix was awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by gqn wired magazine so just go to
helix h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
inside take their two-minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at helix
dot com slash inside that's helix
sleep.com
inside for up to 200 off and two free
pillows and now a word from our sponsor
better help
one of my favorite sponsors by the way
uh ryan what does burnout mean to you
not like you see these guys that are
burnouts
like that's different well it's
completely different
just uh being
depleted depleted of energy overworked
overworked not making enough time for
yourself yep have you guys felt burnt
out i i know i have i constantly feel
burnt out
it feels to me like
i just don't have energy to do anything
and you know you've got to take time for
yourself you've got to pay attention to
your body your mind and and better help
is there for us ryan i know still uses
better help a lot of my listeners yep
listen to better help
life can be overwhelming
it sure can and many people are burned
out without even knowing it symptoms can
include lack of motivation irritability
fatigue and more we associate burnout
with work but that's not the only cause
any of our roles in life can lead us to
feel burned out
better help online therapy wants to
remind you to prioritize yourself i
don't know how many times i say this on
the podcast be good to you be good to
yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
um i know that i get so in my head
that i sometimes don't know what to do
next i don't i'm overwhelmed with life
i'm overwhelmed and i just tend to go
back into the bedroom and just fall on
my bed and try to sleep it off
instead of dealing with my [ __ ]
if i could say that i don't think better
help it cares it's real stuff here i'm
talking about
but
talking to a therapist talking to
someone someone who's objective someone
who can you know who listen to you who's
a professional
it helps it really truly helps and um
don't take my word for it take ryan's
word for it take
take uh all the patrons and all the
people around the world that use
betterhelp yeah take their word for it
yeah
um betterhelp is customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy i
can tell you that especially living out
here in california you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours and
our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
inside
that's betterhelp
betterhelp.com
inside
do you
like
i mean you play these roles i mean these
intense roles you're either
heroic or you're this villain or what do
you prefer because you're a funny guy do
you want to play more comedic roles
because you have that comedic charm even
even in peacemaker yeah well the james
is is uh
the gateway i mean he's the one that
kind of unleashed that and gave me the
opportunity to kind of have fun with
that and i'm also getting more confident
in myself as a performer that i think i
can do more and more things it's a
complex what you're talking about is
very comp it's it's to me it's very
layered um
i think i'm in a unique situation
because of the way i came up in the
business i came up as a guy that started
with roger corman i could do my own
stunts i could fight i happened to be
fairly suitable looking for the camera
and i kind of worked my way in that way
you know what i'm saying yeah and uh i
have a street cred and sort of something
to back it up right and
and that overcame my lack of formal
training
you didn't really have that much
training no no no no i came out here i
lived in my car for a couple couple
weeks uh i didn't know anybody i didn't
have an agent what year is this 1984. 84
you came out here live in your car you
didn't have an agent and by the way i
hear that you like i read somewhere you
didn't even want to act when you were
younger like you didn't really have it
like well yeah you you've done some
great
research ah dug deep um well my first
acting experience uh it was my mother uh
who kind of got me doing like some print
ads in georgia for like rich's
department store but i was chosen to be
peter pan and play in third grade and i
was kind of embarrassed about that and
the guys and then there was the question
of you got to wear the tights and i'm
like what the [ __ ]
i don't think so it'll be green
corduroys for me and uh
you know at third grade i think that you
know what what year was it 67 or
something like that i did i did peter
pan and you know what i loved it
really i mean i as far as i can think
back to my mind uh what i was thinking
at however old i was just an excitement
i loved it i jumped out on stage hi i'm
peter band from never never like you
played peter pan i was peter
it was just a school play but i think it
was enough michael that it it it kind of
made me go
acting
right and you remember when i grew up
well you don't remember but i mean
i grew up in a time
when you didn't have this
i know you didn't have games
you didn't have any of that [ __ ] yeah
you had a baseball you had a football
you had a gun
you had a gun yeah how old were you when
you had a bb guns oh okay little baby
you you had you had the woods
right oh yeah you had a dog you had some
friends you had a bike and you went out
and created your fun that's true and you
acted we acted like we were in vietnam
that was my childhood so
essentially i've just
figured out a way to professionally
prolong
my childhood and now i'm 63 with aches
and pains and you know
was it what was it did your mother go
you know what you were really good in
that was she very supportive what would
your dad say at that point would you
like no no no son of mine's going to be
an actor no my dad and my mom were more
they were more
they're very fear-based people
really yeah explain that well they were
born during you know world war ii and
they were raised in the post
uh
great depression era right my mother was
incredibly poor growing up
her father abandoned her when she was
11. wow
and
she didn't see him again until she was
married uh and had kids
uh my father was a uh the son of a
career soldier
uh my grandfather
was tattoo right here my grandfather was
uh
world war one he ran off and joined more
he ran off and joined the army
he came out he went to school university
of new hampshire played football there
after the war
and then had a restaurant in boston and
then went off to world war ii when it
broke out he enlisted
and then he was in korea bronze star
awarded a bronze star
and so my father and my mother both were
very fear-based right so they're afraid
of everything so then i know you're
trying to get inside me right where are
they i'm going to put up a parameter no
but were they afraid that you were going
to they were fearing that you might fail
at this exactly
that's what you're getting exactly right
if you
i i don't want i don't want to
make my parents well my dad's dead but i
don't want my parents to really i don't
want my mother to feel bad about this
but you know there was
when you hear when you hear these
sayings that the
don't share your goals with people or
don't tell people what you plan to do or
what you hope to do because your friends
and family or be the ones that are going
to discourage you the most
that's what i came from
really
i think that with acting i think all
parents discourage their kids absolutely
you know i think there was a part of me
my dad
i was in college i was doing a play and
i was like i want to be an actress like
eat your steak
i was at denny's eat your steak
he was like come on shut up you're going
to college here you're going to be an
actor what are the odds of you becoming
anything in your life that's
you know he was alluding to it it's a
crap shoot it's a crap shoot so it's a
genuine crap yeah so after peter pan
that's why we love guys like james gunn
because his his whole career is a crap
shoot i mean it's the same steve agee
all of us we're all that guy we are that
guy however we got there that we said
you know what [ __ ] it i want to be a
movie guy i want to do tv i want to act
i want to perform that's what i want to
do
so that's why we all get along when we
come to los angeles i think it's like
it's like this bouillabaisse of all
these people that were
the same way you want to pretend and
play yeah well you said a few minutes
ago you said something that kind of like
i let it go because you were talking but
you said something about how
about your your confidence level or
something about your nerves you're still
you're still you know finding that
you're still i look at you somebody who
has total confidence now i do now you
have total confidence now i do with
everything
i mean your lies without acting without
oh [ __ ] yeah i get nervous you do
[ __ ] yeah
i think you're i think you're if you
don't get nervous you should be worried
i mean do you get nervous yeah
i mean it's it's uh as confident as i am
right and and believe you me
acting
is
a relaxation
and confidence game
that's what it is
you have got to relax
you have got to be confident
and then
that means when the nerves pop up you've
got to know how to deal with that
you got to deal with it on the spot how
long did it take you to learn that
well i have a great acting coach
who's that stephen bridgewater stephen
bridgewater you still see your stephen
stephen bridgewater is my man
now i i may call him and i may send him
something you don't need me
we're at that point now where he'll you
don't need me you know really yeah and
peacemaker was one of those ones you
don't need me you don't need me for this
and you just do it on your own and well
i've learned i've been with the guy for
you know almost
25 years what do you do to relax what do
you do to get that confidence well
because you're saying you're nervous at
first well part of the part of the way i
get i get the confidence is is something
that stephen told me as well which is
you're always going to work
so let's eliminate that part
that
you're always going to work wow so that
anxiety
move it
that fear get rid of it you're good no
you're good you're good you are good you
you
are good
yeah
and you it took you probably some time
to believe that i never had anybody tell
me that
even after i'd done you know even after
i'd done t2 i was still kind of even
after t2 and that's a hell of a [ __ ]
performance even more as i go further
and further and further away from it i
go like i didn't realize
how
i got into it
to the level i got
and it's not just me it's it's ilm it's
it's stan winston it's all i got but
that character is a
that's a hell of a thing and you hadn't
done much before that i'd only done
roger corman well you did a die small
party very small part in die hard too
renee harlan cast me on the spot so as i
was getting into hollywood i was
i was learning as i was going and i had
no mentor i had no one no one really to
plot or chart uh and uh any career no
career advice i mean i had i had my wife
who loved me by that time and you're
still with your wife oh i love myself
you're one of the rare breeds man i love
my wife you've been with her since what
ninety 90 1984 i met her right away i
met her very soon after i got here she
was my angel she was she was one she was
one of them that said
you're going to make it
you know and if you got a couple people
like that that believe in you and you're
looking for some sort of an assurance
yeah because you don't know yeah wonder
you think maybe i got a shot at this
isn't that true you got to have like
that one person or a few people in your
life throughout the years that goes
it keeps giving you the shot
inside of you is brought to you by geico
geico asks how would you love a chance
to save some money on insurance of
course you would after all who doesn't
love a great deal right and when it
comes to great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life
geico can help like with insurance for
your car truck motorcycle boat and rv
even help with homeowners condo or
renter's coverage you could save even
more with a special discount when you
bundle your coverages plus add the easy
to use geico mobile app available 24
hour roadside assistance and more and
choosing to switch to geico becomes an
easy choice switch today and see all the
ways you could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save hey folks this
is michael rosenbaum and i am excited to
tell you about talkville it's every
wednesday it's the new smallville
rewatch podcast
talkville you could watch it on youtube
you could listen to wherever you get
your podcast ryan's involved i am it's a
blast you get to rewatch all these [ __ ]
the show that you never even saw no yeah
so it's a first watch for me it is a
first watch and tom welling and i will
then uh critique and talk about the
episodes with your help and your
questions and it's going to be an
absolute blast if you want to follow us
on the handles on twitter it's at
talkvillepod and on instagram and
facebook at talkville podcast we
appreciate all your love all your
support please keep listening inside of
you but also check out talkville every
wednesday
i had a casting director who used to
always just call me in and say hey we're
going to get you something you've got
this you've got this and you know i i
wouldn't get a part i wouldn't get a
part and then she was she kept fighting
for me she always fought for me she saw
something in me that i didn't see yeah
and you and you you
you're you're aware you know in your
head you know you you just need that i
mean you're you're
you're thinking and i don't know what
you're religious at i don't know where
you are religiously i have a deep deep
commitment to god so i'm a cat you know
anglo catholic right and uh
so i have that relationship but i'm also
looking for
you know i'm not i shouldn't say i'm
looking for it it's just nice to get an
external
you don't know how that'll do like
you'll say that to somebody and you
don't think it's a big deal i feel so
much better right now and then and then
i know i tend to get kind of deep
this is real [ __ ] but this is uh this is
where you're
you people don't realize the impact they
have and just what a kind word
can do for someone yeah that person
could be waiting to hang on to that
that kindness that you gave them
and it could lift them up to do things
you'll never know i mean if
if if if we all look back and see who
who gave us that that kept us going when
we were thinking about maybe it's over
you know maybe who was it who was who
was well my wife was one when i when i
got out here she
she saw you at your lows too well she
saw me when i was a broke dick dude and
and she literally got on stage with me
when i didn't know what the [ __ ] i was
doing and and i [ __ ] had a
you know i i was awful
what do you mean on stage i got on stage
and did a scene with her in front of a
bunch of people on a showcase at al's
bar and i sucked
you you don't forget that you remember
this like i could tell i didn't even
know what the [ __ ] i was doing and i
swear to myself at that time i went like
that will never happen again so you
almost thought like i'm gonna quit
acting no no no no no i went boy you
didn't know what you're getting into you
didn't really realize how much you know
you weren't prepared you weren't you
were not prepared you don't know how to
prepare you don't even know what the
[ __ ] you're doing
you can't just [ __ ] wing it
wow you [ __ ] so you were just going
on natural talent you know i could just
do this based on like you know yeah and
i'm just good enough
i don't even know if i was saying i was
good enough i was going like i'm just
gonna [ __ ] and keep going until somebody
says you can't do this anymore
really you know what i mean yeah
was was cameron one of those guys
when you're doing t2 was he one of the
guys who was like hey great job really
great job i love that he was he was
always that guy he was yes yes he was
yeah and and and you know i don't want
to gloss over the fact that i really owe
him a
i owed him
in my career i mean you know james
cameron is really the guy that uh
saw all that bundle of insecurity and
you know and all that stuff that i had
going on and said
you can [ __ ] do this
right he did say that you know when i i
read the script and i came into him
it's a long i'm not gonna we don't have
enough time to get in the whole [ __ ]
t2 thing and there's tons of times i've
talked about but you know after i read
the script which took like five [ __ ]
hours i walked in and i put the thing
down and then i
i can do this
and he
that's why you're here robert
that's what he said
that's why you're here
yeah and that that was pretty amazing
and that was it and i got the role
and that changed your life oh yeah gave
me my career
that one role gave me my career because
you were broke i had nothing
the money i'd made on die hard too i
bought a barber an engagement ring
i was still living at the hollywood tire
tower at franklin argo are you serious
yeah is that haunted that place no
i thought it was taunted with
your ghosts my ghosts your ghosts wow so
that made you and the door started
opening
people started calling you your agent
you had an agent at this point
i did
i did i had an agent that got me t2
and then and then like
every person that gets a big movie and
the other big agencies come circling
around i made a move right and it was
one of the biggest movies ever and well
i made it well i made a move to a bigger
agent oh yeah yeah that's what happens
isn't it and then i felt bad about that
and then and then i was over my head
so it was it's weird i think about it
now i i mean
there's a lot i feel like i lost a lot
of momentum t at t after t2
for a number of reasons
and i'm going to talk about this because
i feel very comfortable talking to us
i'm an alcoholic
now i'm not turning this into an aah no
a lot but i am an alcoholic and i had a
i was a big substance abuser an
alcoholic prior to t2
and i got myself clean and sober for t2
because i knew that i could not do that
film
with the recreational activities that i
had going on nor was i going to be able
to drink i was i had to go and be a monk
i had to focus i had to do the film
and when it's over
of course
i go back and
hit it hard in a big way right because
now i've accomplished something
and
you'd think if i may interject that you
think that after doing that and getting
off the booze and having such success
that you think oh well look what
happened when i got off the booze but
that wasn't the mindset because it's an
addiction not for this guy no i wasn't
mature enough to handle even though i
was 30 years old you know i was 30 when
that 31 when that came out
um
and
i rewarded
myself by partying for
[Music]
like two years you know like three years
like four years right until i finally
realized
what am i doing i'm i've destroyed this
great gift of momentum i've gotten i've
you really destroyed it you can tell you
destroyed it oh i feel so i feel like i
did like with what i don't think i would
put i don't think i prepared myself for
some of the opportunities i was
presented and therefore didn't get the
jobs
i think that uh
had i had
a little bit more of a mentor-ish
relationship with someone that could
have
because i shifted agents at the same you
know i left my agent with some new
agents and they didn't really know me
and they didn't know how
crazy and insecure i was and
they didn't know my story and i think
they just thought they could just you
know and i didn't handle it well i did
not have i was not prepared for i wasn't
prepared for being famous all of a
sudden and michael i wasn't really
famous
because no one knew who the [ __ ] robert
patrick was
i was
the guy from tbt2 i was the t1000 did
you hate that
no
uh it was it was a it was a terrifying
thing though
i mean
to the point where i realized i'm not
going to get another job either because
if i look like like like like i look
like i look like now it's kind of like
when i you know and that's the way i
carry myself now but at the time i
decided
i need to gain some weight i need to
grow my hair along i need to grow a
beard i need to get away from this guy
if i'm ever going to get hired again and
it was a year and a half before i got
hired again and what was it
uh what was the first movie yeah fire in
the sky great movie thank you but there
was a lot of psychosis to get to that
and even that when i was hitting the
bottle a little bit but by the way was
it as close as close as you came to
maybe losing your wife when you were
because being an alcoholic is probably
not something fun to be around
yeah
barbara bar it's funny my wife she
doesn't she even though i am an
alcoholic and i know i am she doesn't
think i am and i go well babe you know
if you get drunk every day of the week
you're
pretty much a [ __ ] alcoholic
i mean you know yeah if there's uh if
there's a reason you know if you're
getting high every day of the week i
mean you know
it might be a problem and it's not hard
being in hollywood and going through
that i i you know michael when i got
here and i'm not going to throw any of
my old my
buds under the bus but
that was what you did
you worked you made money you went on a
party hard you went on unemployment
and you partied to deal with whatever
and you played golf or whatever you did
to you waited for that next gig and you
worked hard on that gig and you did that
gig and got that money then you party
well usually they say you got to hit
rock bottom before you change your ways
did you hit rock bottom i don't think i
hit rock bottom i i was i was still
relatively successful um
i'm giving it to you from my perception
like i think i blew my opportunity right
after t2 what do you think could have
happened
i just feel like if i was more prepared
and
had a little bit more
confidence going back to the confidence
in my i still lacked my i didn't have
enough confidence in my uh abilities as
an actor
even though i pulled that role off i
wasn't sure i could do everything right
and the lack of training i had
uh before i got into hollywood was
holding me back and this is just me this
is just the [ __ ] thing in your head
this is my headquarters and you never
went to therapy or anything no because
that's not how you were brought up no
that you that's a stigma crazy that's
nuts you're dead you couldn't do that
your mom wouldn't do that you're not
doing that i'm not crazy that's the
mentality that's the mentality to this
day if you can go back you probably
would see a therapist abso [ __ ]
lutely yeah
and i have right
but i come from that time period where
you know you didn't if you had a problem
like my grandfather had a problem after
all the wars he just drank every night
right and my dad was the son of an
alcoholic and my mother
her father
he was an alcohol that's how you dealt
with things
well that that is how you dealt with
things
and it's probably still how you deal
with things
today
when's the last time you had a drink
26 years ago
you want to know how i quit michael i'm
going to give credit here i i hope i can
do that please
i would like to lift people up instead
of bringing them down and i'm going to
say
uh i was working with demi moore
and i was doing striptease oh yeah
and i played her drunken
redneck
husband probably the most
true to casting i've ever had wow i
remember that too i don't know
you were yeah
uh
yeah i like timmy and and they may like
me we got along really really well and
um
um
she said to me at one point she said you
know i feel like you have a real anger
issue
on the set one day and i said really
she said yeah
and then she and i thought about that
what the [ __ ] does that mean like i i'm
not angry at her or anything but what is
that you know
i was drinking about two to three
bottles of wine at night on that movie
that's a wow that's a lot of wine that's
a lot and i wouldn't even leave my hotel
i was in there by myself anyway was it
affecting your work i don't think so
because i thought you were part in that
movie
you were it helped me yeah uh but you
couldn't forget what she was saying yeah
yeah i mean i i just it was one of those
things and i thought i mean it was it
was constructive
i feel like you're dealing with you know
i don't know
what made that happen but she had a
psychic that came on the set and uh a
gal that does a reading and she you know
uh um
me and the gal went to my trailer we did
this reading and this gal said i see
alcohol all around you it was like the
first thing she said
and i listened to that and i thought
about it and she was telling me about my
my my grandparents my ancestors and all
that kind of stuff and
i started going like i think i have a
[ __ ] problem
and
that was pretty much my bottom
uh that and when i told my wife i wanted
to have kids and she said are you out of
your [ __ ] mind
you want to have kids you think i'm
going to have kids with you
why don't you try to get off the
recreational drugs for a year or two so
i don't have any
you know any problems having a kid yeah
we'll take it from there
and how old are your kids now my
daughter's 25. so it was right
after so let me tell you something
michael
when you can look your your kids in the
eye and say
i literally
got sober
to conceive you to have you that's how
much thought planning went into you
it's pretty powerful that is intensely
powerful and both of them know it
my son who's 21
is a song and dance man
he's at boston conservatory berkeley
school of music my daughter austin
patrick
is a college graduate a newly minted
actress she's getting out there she's
done a few things she's done a few
little movies austin patrick for any of
you
listening
she's she's in hollywood auditioning are
you helping her out she got her sag card
in a movie i produced really yeah while
she was in college
uh she went to bennington and she
graduated with a degree in liberal arts
and uh studied film and
and uh literature and and all that while
she was there and she wants to uh she
wants to pursue it she's born and raised
here i never
my kids always did schools uh do you
have children no
look at where i live look at the movie
posters do you think i have children
look i'm a child your house is
i think your house is very cool thanks i
know i rushed right in here to do this i
can't i had no book business and you
know just jump last i loved it i love
that you just jumped in so uh uh it's
fantastic i love it you got to come out
to my dealership and see my dealerships
do you have a car dealership i own a
harley-davidson dealership are you
serious yeah santa clarita california
it's not far
you need to come on out it's movie
posters it's all my memorabilia t2
arcade it's sort of a my guys kind of go
like yeah we know who owns this place oh
i gotta go there for sure it's uh it's i
love harley davids harley davidson saved
my life man i mean it's it's why is that
uh literally i i uh
well
go ahead in brit in brief in brief oh i
got started i got stung by a bee riding
a harley davidson i pulled over on the
side of the road because i felt like i
was having a heart attack and i didn't
realize i was having an anaphylactic
reaction to this piece
i turned off the bike i was straddling
the bike i cast out went into an
anaphylactic
uh i think fever fever whatever yeah so
i went unconscious on the bike
straddling it with the kickstand down
but the bike i had shut it off but the
bike and the pipe was so hot
they woke you up it burned it burned my
leg
they say my adrenal gland reacted as a
result it was like getting an epipen
kicked me back up to life i pulled
myself away from the bike i was on
mulholland highway right across from
calabasas high school
and i passed out in the in the in the
bushes under the trees i can show you
the spot pretty much there it's right
it's right where i grew up actually so
so you know right across the street
under those trees and i'm under there
right at that
anyway
and i pass out again and i wake up and
um
i've pissed myself
sure i'm soaking wet i have [ __ ] and
leaves all over me so obviously i've
been flopping around like trying to
i fought it
and uh i rode home and went and saw my
doctor the next day and he said well
apparently you had a allergic reaction
to this piece thing it was on the side
of your head and you went into an
anaphylactic shock and let me see that
burn and you're lucky to be alive
wow
but michael as i said before uh i i am
uh a christian and
have a deep relationship with god
always since you were well since i was a
kid right and and seriously uh that has
that has if you have that in your life
you've already you've been given a step
up the ladder i think if you have a
grounding in and so you pray you go to
church i pray first thing in the morning
first thing in the morning i roll off
the bed i hit my my knees hit the pillow
on the floor and i pray for i pray for
the fact that i woke up
you do i started the gratitudes i do i
start with i woke up and then list my
gratitudes
every morning every [ __ ] morning
it's your routine it's my routine does
your wife does barbara do that no she
doesn't she religious she has her own
thing she has her own thing she has all
this she goes to church with you she
believes in god
wow but i you know i don't push my
religion
on
anyone
i don't yeah i'm not i'm not even trying
to push it on you i'm just trying to
relate how i get through life yeah and i
think that's what i'm not religious but
i believe in god
i believe what this uh podcast is about
right
and uh you know it's how we cope and how
we deal with the world yeah
uh i'm just as crazy as anybody but you
know i i do think that uh
i think that uh i think that having a
deep foundation and belief in something
is is a leg up yeah having faith in
something is is important it's very
vital even if it's just gravity yeah as
my brother as my brother richard likes
to say gravity gravity i have faith in
gravity okay
do you think
are you someone who has to keep busy all
the time or you'll go crazy do you have
to always be working well i
i think it gives me a real strong sense
of purpose and i need it
uh i need to have something in front of
me
um my discipline has kind of
been changing over the years like i like
walking my dog now
more than i like
running
i like
i like stretching and doing yoga now
more than i do doing weights weights
yeah
uh i still have to kind of stay strong
and
it seems somewhat dangerous for
most the roles i play right but i'm
never gonna look like john cena
you know who can look like john cena
john cena john cena he's the only one
he's [ __ ] amazing he's he's a machine
your relationship is so awesome in that
it's so ridiculous i you know what it's
so great don't we have great great
chemistry great chemistry you know james
didn't even know that
james gunn didn't even know that when we
got cast really no you asked him
he he said to me i see you he saw me an
hbo peacemaker all right hbo uh perry
mason right and he started thinking
about me over the pandemic you know he
was watching perry mason he thought
about me for this role
and he started writing the role for me
for peacemaker that was the impetus for
him
and when we had our zoom meeting we had
a zoom meeting that's how that's how
that's how that went down he said i said
you know i've worked with john
he said i didn't know that i said oh
yeah i played a villain opposite him in
his first film
wow and he went really and i said and
and i said
i said as a matter of fact
we have good chemistry because we
actually get along this is before you
started filming this yeah i hadn't seen
john in like 10 years
uh i worked with him on psych was
another episode we did we did a thing
you did psych i decided to i think two
episodes was julie and yeah james
they've been on here a couple times i
hope i think they like me great guys
they had me on i i don't really know i'm
sure i i had great fun working with them
um uh
but uh uh john and i uh i think uh
uh
he i brought my son to see him wrestle a
couple times i'd love it and john uh
john was super cool with my son my son
maybe you know he's 21 now maybe 10
years ago he was 10. my son was like
going to wrestling academy with luke
perry son out here in the valley rick
drazen's school
and
and john did this thing
i think it was in arizona summerslam or
something or something or other he knew
where we were where we were sitting we
were sitting right close to the right he
had arranged it
and he came into the ring with all that
you know that stuff that he does
he slid across
the ring
came through the ropes and leaned over
and took his hat off and plopped it on
my son's head
and then went back up on stage and
started wrestling
it was like wow coolest [ __ ] intro i
never said that is unremarkable and my
son was just like
you know he'd been touched by thor i
mean yeah he's like you know it's like
it was an amazing thing that's amazing
what a sweetheart so we have a great we
have a great relationship that's great i
hope john says the same thing because i
think we do i think we have a really
good uh
uh a chemistry and i think it works
really well yeah i think it's wonderful
do you feel like people at some point
do you ever feel like they're
intimidated by you that that you're like
why are they intimidated by i'm a loving
fun guy do you ever feel that have you
ever been told that yes
really by who
yeah
yeah i mean that's kind of really hard
to
i mean i can turn it on and turn it off
you know you can be intense you know if
you're not sure about someone or if you
don't trust them maybe you're not as
open you're not as yeah loose yeah yeah
i feel comfortable talking to you right
i know i'm aware of you enough to know
that i can talk to you yeah i mean i
mean we we we we're cool yeah uh i i
don't always um
i'm not always willing to uh
let every
you know everybody in yeah i'm not
always out do you feel like you ever
challenge someone or challenge a new
director to see what they know if they
know what they're doing i can be kind of
grumpy
sometimes with newer directors that
don't uh seem to have an appreciation
for 40 years of work that i've done that
they don't think i'm aware of what
what's going on with my [ __ ] craft
that i can do what i can do right let me
tell you something about james gunn if
i'm please
because i love the guy yeah
first day i worked with him
it's me and john
we've got two scenes in the kitchen
big scenes
i'm prepared john's prepared
there is no question
it's just this all right let's shoot the
rehearsal
we shot the rehearsal now that's the
kind of [ __ ] director i like
uh that is awesome
because i hate
rehearsing and rehearsing
and then i mean i'll do it i'll do
rehearsals but there's nothing like
being loose and ready to go and they're
rolling cameras and you're you know and
even if you're nervous and dealing with
whatever you're dealing with that energy
is great yeah
and uh you know i don't know if i mean
that's the way james worked with me the
first thing i ever did with him was
shoot the rehearsal
wow
so i was like [ __ ] yeah because i love
clint that was the first impression you
got oh yeah this guy's great this is
going to be this guy's defensive yeah i
mean this hallelujah i didn't know that
was coming right and uh uh uh you know
i've worked with clint eastwood twice
he's that way billy bob thornton is
another guy i've collaborated with he's
that way yeah there's just something
about it because it's a respect of i'm
prepared i'm prepared and this is not
only my time but it's your time yeah and
we gotta go and you've hired me and i
get it i've also endured
i don't really know if i feel
comfortable
i've also been around and been on sets
where great big name actors have
deliberately sabotaged the shooting
schedule
either
uh
in inadvertently or or purposely i i you
know but they have definitely taken
steps to slow down production because of
their own vanity and uh process right
and that much and that's much with some
of the older actors that come from
that period of i don't want to give up
real estate to a certain individual and
i don't i want to dominate this
character and it's the character and
it's not me it's this and i don't like
this blocking it's all that kind of [ __ ]
you go like
oh boy and you kind of have to suck it
up and just go i don't think there's
time for that now in this day and age i
mean you work all the time now i think
people people hire you they come in and
they expect you to do your job yeah i
mean when i worked with clint eastwood
uh on uh uh uh flags of our fathers he
he loved clint i worked with clint he's
a great what did you do i did this movie
called midnight in the garden good and
evil i had one big scene in the
courtroom great yeah i loved him he was
like this is a great movie he was the
best director in terms of just like he
would just do your thing shoot it and
then you go
that was great just uh this take just
acknowledged the jury
that's all i need you to do
i go do you have anything else because
no how did you feel i go i felt great he
goes all right you want another one
he ju and he wouldn't even say action
remember he would just say he'd just go
jack to jack green his dp and you just
do that rolling oh yeah motion oh yeah i
loved i loved clint he was such a great
that was my first real movie my friend
with him well i gotta tell you i gotta
go back and watch that and and i loved
your impersonation of him too by the way
and and that's exactly the scenario yeah
i did uh uh um
neil mcdonough and i did it
he was on here oh was he yeah i love
neil i love neil i love his uh love of
catholicism yeah oh yeah he's got an
animal family he's a wonderful wonderful
guy
um
we were doing the outline uh uh the
parameters of the invasion of iwo jima
on this uh on the uss merchant marine
ship that's down there in the
long beach i can't remember the name of
the [ __ ] boat anyway and they
literally took it out and sailed it
around to catalina we were out in the
pacific ocean sailing around a boat with
a bunch of extras and
it was a lot of dialogue and i had just
done a lot of dialogue for david mammoth
the day before on my tv show the unit so
i was like double duty with two
monologues and i was a little concerned
that
[ __ ] can you do this well some of the
other stuff was bleeding into some of
the other stuff and i was starting to
get confused because there were some
numbers and there was some
uh you know what i mean right are you an
actor yeah what is your job
what the [ __ ] he is an engineer he's a
comedian
i'm just kidding what are you doing ryan
so uh we are we are uh we're out there
doing that thing and we're doing the
scene and uh with this and and he
literally had the cameras back and i'm
rehearsing like crazy i got a blackboard
uh where they were going to shoot the
scene and i'm kind of like referencing
and i'm kind of running the lines and
kind of and there's you know just all
these extras and reason
[ __ ] dude
i had a real that was probably the most
anxious i've ever been but i bet you he
relaxed you
well i was doing that you know alexander
techniques and breathing and you know
breathe with your [ __ ] and you know
you got to kind of breathe through your
feet and you got to squeeze your butt
cheeks i'm doing it now you got to think
about those you got to do all that [ __ ]
you really do yeah yeah and you're
sucking it in and you're kind of going
and it's exhausting you're exhausted in
those days when you're nervous or when
you're going through all that stuff the
exhaustion just piles up on oh man it's
the worst piles on and you and these
young actors like uh paul walker and all
these guys are looking at you like yeah
these guys are [ __ ] fats man they
know what the [ __ ] they're doing
and you're like yeah well and i i did go
up the second take but anyway the first
take the first day we got to was
flawless and they applauded and it was
two cameras far back and then clint
moved him up and he didn't come up to
him and he finally now he's he's walking
i've never really met him and he he says
to me and neal he goes yeah i've never
really been able to do those monologues
like that
i really admire you guys for
wow that's that's not easy you did a
nice job
it was it was actually that's awesome it
was really really cool it was
self-deprecating and i admire you for
that and
a quick joke and i know i'm taking a lot
of time no we're almost done i'm going
to ask you these other questions and
we're done quick joke about not joke but
quick funny story about clint
second film i did with him trouble with
the curve he's an actor
uh i'm his boss i only i'm the general
manager of the land of braves he's one
of my he's one of my scouts wow matthew
lillard is a new scout who's all about
tech
gus is old school it's all about gut
right amy adams john goodman matthew
luther's clint eastwood seen in a
conference room trouble with the curve
i'm doing dialogue and i have a bit of
dialogue where i say in a slight
georgian accent
well how about you gus you're on
extension on your contract
now whatever i said or however i said it
it was funny to him and it's i'm pretty
sure that was the line
and it was funny now
and it got to be every time i did that
line you want an extension on your
contract
he would laugh he would laugh
and he had a big monologue and i watched
him work with the script girl like run
the line and he never got it the same
way twice but he got it but he never got
the same way twice right but it was good
enough good enough yeah
so the camera's coming around on me and
everybody's got a little part to play in
this thing and everybody's got a little
thing and i got my thing and now they're
doing my coverage
and he is now
and i don't know if it's from relief of
doing the monologue
and he's the pressure's off him right
he starts laughing and giggling
the the giggles we don't want to have
that we get sometimes oh yeah he can't
stop him you can't stop him yeah
and he can't stop
is it making you laugh it's well dude
it's clint eastwood [ __ ] eastwood bro
and you're sitting here looking at him
going like
you got to be kidding me
now i'm getting pissed yeah because my
[ __ ] coverage
and it's and i'm going like
and now i'm preoccupied with is he going
to start giggling off camera now that's
what you're thinking about you're not
even thinking of yourself now i
literally have to say to him and he's
not the director
are you gonna [ __ ] you can't do that
[ __ ] on my close-up for [ __ ] sake
seriously you gotta i mean
it's coming around me and i'm laughing
too but
this is crazy what did he say he's
giggling he can't help it i'm sorry i'm
sorry
he pushed him it's not yours it's my
fault my fault michael i swear to you
i'm not making this up he's he's he's
giggling so bad he's he's his eyes are
watering
he's crying
and his guys are looking at me and
they're going it's kind of a big deal
these guys are looking at me going like
i haven't seen him lose it like that in
25 years
wow ask lillard that is i will ask you
guys
he'll tell you he'll tell you i love him
it was funny as it was it was funny
you'll never forget that never forget
that and i and i love working with clint
and uh i hope i get to work with him
again yeah
and if he hears this i love him i think
he's a great guy he's great he's uh he
always had lunch with me
and i and me being all the other actors
that were all we were there working that
day
and that's bruce springsteen
my theme song always remember
how i treat baby no
surrender oh that's a good song thank
you very much this is it [ __ ] talking
with robert patrick i love you [ __ ]
talking with robert these are my patrons
am i allowed in these candidates no
you're awesome you sound great
okay ryan not rudy rudy that's your new
nickname hashtag rooney hashtag
[Applause]
i got a lot of connections to the name
rudy but that's ryan i apologize that's
all right my nephew's name is ryan i
don't know where rooney is my
grandfather's rudy i got my best friend
named rudy and that's a great movie
right i was attacked up there too this
is this is it [ __ ] talking about the
title robert these are my patrons they
give back to the uh podcast a lot i love
you guys you uh because you smell like
patreon.com
these are these are i've been talking
about alcohol all day
this is rapid fire so you're going to
answer them fast
regret this go
st steph a between working with james
cameron and james gunn which one did you
have more fun working with change gun
just like that
leanne you've played so many iconic
roles over the years which one do you
identify with the most
it's rapid but you don't you can take
your time on some questions
max kennard gangster squad
really that's the one character
i like how focused you are for rapid
fire i'm looking at linda blair from the
exorcist i'm sorry this is rapid fire
but dude i got some [ __ ] i got a long
[ __ ] career
no
scratch that
max kenneth is not right john doggett
x-files
really yeah that's the character i love
the most oh that's a great character
yeah i love john dodge clawdeen what was
it like coming in she's not even
australian what is it like coming into
such a popular show like the x-files in
the eighth season was it hard to find
your place in the show no
why because
cause why chris carter wrote such a
great role
[Music]
raj what was your way into the what was
your way into the role of auggie smith
and peacemaker any interesting research
you had to do to prepare yes what'd you
do
i just listened to the news
[Music]
you just listened to the news
correct okay
i love this
danny i love you michael i want to do
another one of these you have to this is
a blast danny when robert pops up in
wayne's world i remember the whole movie
theater just screaming was he proud to
have created a character so iconic that
t1 would be instantly recognized even in
a different genre
that was part of how i started to
realize that it was uh uh like such an
iconic role
that was when it started to dawn on me
when uh michael what's his name that uh
does saturday night
no no no mike meyer no the guy the
producer
lauren noah lauren michaels lauren
michaels yeah
when he insisted to mike myers that i
play the cop and mike myers was
resistant and didn't want me to play the
cop
but when
lauren michaels insisted and had me play
the cop
and it got such a big laugh probably the
biggest laugh in the movie
and i'm sitting next to penelope's
ferris in the chinese man theater and
we're both kind of like it she goes she
leans over and goes
i think you got the biggest laugh in the
film
how about that huh pretty good pretty
damn good ben jay everybody loves cop
land what are your memories from working
with the superb ensemble cast and
director james mangold you remember the
story i was telling you about the actors
yeah which one um
[Music]
oh
oh yeah yeah
[Music]
not easy
james mangle
is one of the most
talented directors
writers
in the business
and i think about this uh
incredible filmmaker yeah he cast you
again didn't he and yes
i love james i can't wait to work with
him again because he's another one he's
a gem he's a he's a
mango likes to rehearse a little bit
more but he's kind of he's such a
i love mingle
what was it like working with walking
phoenix by the way i love joaquin was he
very uh he's one of the sweetest guys
really one of the sweetest men i've ever
been around love him dearly seriously i
love him last question yes sir jennifer
r what is it like being a part or face
of cgi history between t-1000 and
jurassic park the 90s were amazing
well i'm very proud to be the first
motion capture actor in the history of
film
you are i know i didn't realize that
until
steve spaz williams there's a
documentary out right now yes let's plug
it it's called
spazz isn't he the one that really
created all the stuff yeah the visual
and then he like lost his career for a
while and then checked the documentary
yeah have him on the show do you know
him yes what a great he was he reminded
me he said robert
you're the first motion capture actor in
the history of film when we were doing
his documentary about him you're the
first guy
it was my idea
to paint the grid on you
remember before they used to when they
did the film when edison was doing the
films of they wanted to shave a horse
ever left the earth and they painted the
squares on the grid and they had the
horse running in front of the grid yep
well steve very sensibly said i'm going
to put the grid on him
and then film him
and that'll be the three dimension i
need to fit into the computer wow he
thought about that he was the one who
thought about i'm i mean dude
brilliant one of those guys that you're
around and you just look and go like my
god like what do you talk about with a
guy like that oh smart
you talk to him what you talk to me
about
yeah
i will this has been a real joy you're a
great guy i look forward to working with
you
well let's do it let's do something get
me in the peacemaker i already told
james i want to be in the peacemaker
james gunn if you listen to michael
i'm going to tell you right now he'd be
fantastic yes sir james you hear that i
would love to see him i'd love to have
him up there and work with us
hopefully i get to work because i am
dead for those of you well you're dead
but there's the ghost yeah well that's
true there's things that are happening
and to be honest with you i'm looking
more
you know you've talked about life
i think that this could be the funniest
[ __ ] stuff ever with the dad is the
ghost i love i mean in my own mind i'm
trying to think of the scenarios james
is going to come up with and there's a
lot he could do oh yeah it's unlimited
yeah because i'm a [ __ ] ghost
i'm a [ __ ] ghost dude i'd love it you
are a ghost hey thank you i'm going to
see you at the wedding
yes i'm going to be there i'm going to
be there however let's put out a little
caveat yeah
schedule permitting schedule permitting
like if i get a job if i'm doing
something you got to take a job sure
all right i love this this is great for
all of you people who live in the
southern california area this saturday a
second when does this air
uh i don't know yet
cinco de mayo is this weekend and out at
harley-davidson of santa clarita we're
gonna have tacos and free soft drinks
yeah head out to his harley
harley-davidson of santa clarita we've
got
harley davidsons and tacos if you're
gonna buy harley davidson you gotta go
to robert patrick for the best i love
him the harley-davidson experience in
southern california
that's harley davidson of santa clarita
where can people follow you on twitter
follow me at
robertpatrickt2 and what about instagram
rip
fighter one word rip fire all right
we're gonna hang out i like this guy all
right maybe he's a blast all right
thanks for coming bye bye
that was really enjoyable he was uh he
kind of speaks his mind let's just say
he does he does
and i really appreciate that blanche
come on hey come on come on out good
girl blanche is still weather she's been
hanging out she just can't get enough
she probably has to go pee
but uh that can wait uh he was a great
guest i really appreciate having on you
on the show patrick thanks for coming on
um
don't forget to tune in to talkville
every wednesday
and um
that's the new rewatch podcast and i
think you guys are gonna really like it
the first episode a lot of people wrote
in and really appreciated it and loved
it and uh the fans are calling in and
it's just it's a collaborative effort
and i'm having a lot of fun so there's
that uh also go to patreon.com
inside of you to become a patron
top tiers get all sorts of perks but you
could just uh support the podcast by
going to patreon.com inside of you
go to the inside of you online store if
you want some cool merch and smallville
autograph stuff i'll be in raleigh july
29th through the 31st
uh signing autographs doing a smallville
nights with tom welling and i'll be in
boston um for a con august 12th
that is about it um
ryan get anything else
uh
no just um
yeah kind of surprised that i
missed
miss kovalev jesus god i'm glad you did
i mean it feels like we haven't been
recording for a lot i don't think we've
recorded much i got to get back in the
groove of things because well there's
been a lot of vacations a lot of
vacations a lot of you taking vacations
me taking a vacation and now we're back
hopefully we'll put some in the can and
uh got some great guests coming up so
please stay tuned if you came for robert
patrick uh stick around for other ones
please subscribe and um
follow us on all our handles
at insiderbepod on twitter inside to be
podcast on instagram and facebook and
now let's read the top tier patrons
let's get we're going to do this these
are the people that give back the most
um for inside of you and i don't know
what i would do without you i seriously
do not
know what i would do i'd probably move
let's be frank
nancy d leah s sarah v little lisa ukico
jill e brian h nigo p robert b jason w
kristen k raj joshua d cjp jennifer n
stacy l jamal f janelle b kimberly
r
e correct mike eldon supremo 99 more
ramirez santiago m chad w liam p janine
r maya p
maddie s belinda
n correct chris h david sheila g brad d
ray
uh h correct top of the t tom and
suzanne b liliana a talia m betsy d
chad l marion med k dan n
big stevie w angel m rhiannon c corey k
dev
nixon michelle a jeremy c andy t gav and
nater david r
c c john b
brandy d euvoir camille s the c joey m
david h design
otg eugene and
ma leah correct chris p nikki g corey
kdb nicole patricia heather l jake b
james b megan t mel s orlando at orlando
c caroline r rob e paul c christine s
sarah s eric h jennifer r shane r m r
m r uh mr not mr it's emma r come on
rosenbaum mark m jeremy v andrew m
robert g
zatoichi
77 cool andreas n alexandra chris r
michael f samantha w and michelle d
thank you guys i couldn't do it without
you
um those are the top tier patrons ryan
uh
cool
yeah there's some new ones there's some
new ones
we will be back next week and we hope
you join us and continue the love and
support of this podcast i know it helps
a lot of people it also helps me so
thank you and uh for myself michael
rosemond the hollywood hills of
california by brian tears
a little way to the camera uh we love
you be sure to be good to yourselves
guys that's the most important thing be
good yourselves have a great week or
weekend or whatever you're doing and uh
be safe we'll see
[Music]